it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week King's Quest fans
get a reimagining of their beloved
series and I say that because while it's
an adventure game it's not
point-and-click King's Quest is a five
chapters story arc as an aging King
Graham reflects on a life of heroism
with his granddaughter Gwendolyn players
are transported back to his experience
firsthand and play through all the
untold tales that shaped a kingdom
chapter one debuts on the 28th also this
week the swindle appears on consoles the
swindle is a steampunk cyber crime caper
about breaking into buildings hacking
their systems stealing all their money
and quickly running away before the
police show up all the buildings you'll
Rob are randomly generated so you'll
never rob the same level twice meanwhile
from the safety of your rickety ship in
space you can modify your thief with new
skills tools and a bunch of
technological mumbo-jumbo allowing you
to take on bigger buildings with more
security for bigger payoffs start
swindling on the twenty-eighth we also
get episode 4 of life is strange and
there's more drama than an episode of
Real Housewives backs realizes that
changing the past can lead to painful
consequences and that time is not a
great healer her investigation into the
disappearance of Rachel amber begins to
reach a thrilling conclusion as she
finds the dark ruse never trust a person
with two first names that's what I
always say the drama starts on the 20th
we you gets a game this week with zio
drifter trademark zo drifter is the
story of an interstellar drifter
traveling stars on a simple mission of
exploration join our Nomad is he embarks
on the investigation of a small cluster
of four planets in the Omega sector
after a collision with a rogue asteroid
damaged his warp core this Metroidvania
like action-adventure game is available
on the 30th finally I get the rest of
this video to convince you to check out
n + + on ps4 it's easy to pick up and
then it slaps you in the face for
thinking of it always be that easy i
played this last year at an event and i
spent the entire night glued to the TV
you're a super smooth stick ninja who
weaves through dangerous environments
this trailer doesn't show a lot of that
but trust me it's good and it comes out
on the twenty-eighth for further details
visit gamespot com release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week
you